in 1927 explorers in baracus Peru
discovered something spectacular
hundreds of human-like skeletons with
incredible elongated skulls researchers
claimed these are humans that underwent
cranial binding as infants a technique
for modifying the shape of the skull a
practice once common in the Americas
Africa and even Europe Gaia comm and
several others have their doubts could
it be that scientists have lied to us
how can we know for ourselves that these
aren't extraterrestrial beings a company
in Los Angeles called bone clones
recently got a hold of the largest known
Peruvian skulls they use them to make
casts and now near-perfect replicas for
the public to witness and study for
themselves you are watching episode 1 of
citizen science versus the aliens of
Peru hello Jackson tonight today we have
gotten hold of an elongated baracus
skull and we've got a normal human skull
here these are both replicas from bone
clones and there's actually a video of
us opening these ok maybe you've seen
that maybe I'm not Jackson tell him
about your glasses you just got new
glasses today first put them like wait
normal humans supposed to see that well
yeah new glasses day for Jackson I also
have horrible eyes I wear contact lenses
but that's besides the point
there are people on the internet that
believe that this elongated skull yeah
some people think that there is a guy on
the internet named Brian Forster he
makes a lot of youtube videos about
these just so you know the normal idea
about what this thing is most people
think that the Baracus people like to
elongate their skulls through cranial
deformation when they have babies they
will put fabric around the head and
forced the skull to grow long instead of
the normal round shape and this is a
really common practice among lots of
different native cultures and even some
European cultures and African cultures
Brien Foerster thinks that there's
something extra special about this he
doesn't think that it's just normal
elongation yeah he claims that he has
measured the overall volume of the
elongated skulls not just the length but
the entire volume and he claims that the
piraka skulls are 25% larger all around
than a normal human skull
now skull binding cannot do that it will
increase the length but it does so by
decreasing the width
therefore he suspects that these skulls
do not belong to normal humans
I suspect that he's wrong but he is
doing good work getting people excited
about you know archaeology right so I
qualify a lot of what he does as
pseudoscience do you know what that is
pseudoscience yeah well if you know
anything about human anatomy and
variation especially normal skull
variation and then you watch Bryan's
videos or read his articles it seems
that what he's doing is he studies the
elongated skulls looking for things
about them that might seem abnormal and
when he finds an abnormality and by the
way every skull you look at will have
some sort of abnormality this is just
because different people are different
from each other when he finds an
abnormality he immediately claims that
this is evidence that the paratus people
are not normal humans and he does this
without checking the scientific
literature to see if those abnormalities
fall within regular human variation
pseudoscience is when you use language
that makes you sound scientific even
though what you're doing is not
scientific you and I have talked a
little bit about what science is right
how would you define science what does a
scientist do so what they do is they
discover tests to see if they're yeah so
sign science is just the collection very
careful collection and documentation of
observable facts things that we can see
with their eyes or taken with our other
senses it's the collection of those
careful documentation of those and then
it's an ongoing discussion about what
those facts might mean Brien Foerster is
sort of doing that so maybe I generally
be calling his work pseudoscience but
the main problem with his work is that
he often ignores the facts that other
researchers have gathered in fact if you
read his book it seems that he hasn't
even read the scientific literature on
scull binding embryology or suture
obliteration these are all topics that
you would have to be well aware of
before being justified in making the
claims that he makes in his book instead
of citing scientific papers he usually
just quotes Wikipedia and I'm not joking
huge chunks of his book are literally
copied and pasted from Wikipedia he does
not go to the source material it's very
strange a lot of people think that this
is an alien because it's slightly
weird-looking now Brien Foerster he
doesn't really support that idea that
this is definitely an alien he thinks
that it might be one of several
different things he thinks that it might
be an alien-human hybrid he thinks it
might be a normal human genetically
engineered by aliens and his book he's
he puts forth the idea of Angel human
hybrid yeah this is the skull it's this
is a replica of a skull that's that's
yeah on his book the other idea that he
says is that this might just be a
different species of humans one that has
never been discovered by science so far
so those are the main ideas that he has
about these this was made by bone clones
and to make it they actually took the
original skull they used it to make a
cast and then they use that cast to make
these replicas of the skull so this
skull is you know millimeter to
millimeter the same as the original it's
a really high quality cast the bone
clones makes and the same goes with this
skull this is a a normal human skull
what I want to do here because science
is about the collection and
documentation of observable facts I want
to just have you and I look at these and
we're gonna look at what's the same and
what's different I mean obviously this
one's way taller at least but what are
some other things that you can see here
that might be
different the eye sockets are this
woman's eye stuck that's a teensy bit
bigger yeah the eye sockets and the
elongated skull are a little bit longer
they're a little bit taller
they're also shallower so it looks like
the overall volume of the eye sockets
has not changed but it's like it's like
someone took a head and smashed it up
like that if you were to take a skull
like this and it was made out of clay
and you were just to roll it like that
it would stretch the eye sockets up a
little bit and stretch the head out and
it looks like something similar to that
happened with this skull through cranial
binding so yes the eyes are taller what
else is different with these anything
else that you notice and what the teeth
yeah she is missing several teeth she's
missing one two three four five she's
kind of got that one it's just broken
out these ones look like they've been
removed and the removal of these two
looks like it happened successfully the
bone healed really nice there but these
two that looks brutal she was probably
in a lot of pain from whatever kind of
surgery she had had there or dental
removal it's you know this skull we
believe is over 2,000 years old yes so
like a native yeah the native Peruvian
yeah what's a Native American cultures
did that and some African and European
but the crazy thing about these teeth
here we don't know for sure if they had
any painkillers
in their culture good painkillers but
today if we have surgery we have teeth
removed we go under you know we don't
feel it at all or we either go under
where they just numb our mouths really
well she might not have had any of that
she might have just gone to her dentist
and they just ripped out those teeth oh
that would have been so brutal and this
poor woman her teeth are also very
ground down but she has normal human
teeth right there's nothing alien about
this Brien Foerster has noted several
differences that you didn't notice
one of the big differences that is that
she is missing a sagittal suture this
guy has all three here you can see that
on the top of his head going towards the
back lines yeah there's the sagittal
suture right there she is missing that
suture just smooth so Brian Forster
noticed that the other thing that he
noticed are these little holes so Brian
Forrester says that these this little
hole here there's actually two little
holes it's kind of hard to see them he
says that these little holes are unique
to elongated skulls that they don't
exist in normal humans those are the
things that he's noted he says that the
elongated skulls can't be normal humans
because they're 25% larger than normal
skulls he says that they can't be humans
because they are missing the sagittal
suture and he says that they can't be
normal humans because they have a hole
here on the back that normal humans
don't have actually two holes on the
back the normal humans don't have so
those are the claims that he has made
and he makes these claims and videos on
YouTube he makes them in his book he
makes them in various articles on on the
Internet
and for these reasons he thinks that
this is not a normal human there's
something weird going on this is
something special something very
different so Jackson we over the next
few weeks we're going to examine each of
these claims starting with the missing
sagittal suture and finally we're going
to actually test the volume of these
skulls I have made a volume testing
apparatus we're going to use Archimedes
principle to measure the volume of an
irregular object being these skulls and
we're going to find out if this one
really is 25% larger than this one I
kind of suspect that it's not and I'll
tell you why look at how big and round
his forehead is look at hers it's
totally flat that's where we're missing
some volume look how big and wide
from-from
- right his skull is and look how narrow
hers is if I set them on the table this
skull is taller then this one is
sideways that makes me suspect that even
though this one is taller this way it's
a way tell if we look at it from this
angle it looks huge super tall see how
much taller hers is even though it's
significantly taller that way I think
that the fact that she has such a flat
forehead and such a reduced besides on
the left and right of the skull I think
that she actually might be close to the
same size
this guy is that's my suspicion I think
that when Brian says that this one is
25% larger than this one I think he
might be exaggerating so we shall see we
will do science to see because what's
lightness scientists do is they
carefully document their observations
and then they talk about what those
observations might mean so we're gonna
start out with an experiment that we're
gonna do on you good people of the
internet next week so make sure that you
are subscribed to our YouTube channel so
that you catch that I guess if you're
watching these videos long after they've
been posted onto YouTube you can just
watch the one we're going to do next
week right now you know lucky you but
for the rest of you for those of you
watching this as we make them we will be
producing these videos every Friday see
you soon
[Music]
you